this weekend many of us millions of us  are going to pack away our thanksgiving  leftovers and maybe put up a christmas  tree although there is a shortage this  year you know last year many tree  farmers oversold during the height of  the pandemic the demand for a real tree  higher than normal this year well  there's also an artificial tree shortage  because of supply chain issues  we're trying to bring in more products  into the country than our ports are  designed to handle and so everything's  getting delayed  the cost to import artificial trees here  to the u.s from asia that's up about 300  percent and much of that cost as you  imagine is being passed on to you